Okay, how are we going to make this.
When I have a complicated
project in front of me,
I like to break it up
into smaller pieces.
So, let's start there.
Here's our high level to-do list.
First, we need to convert a newly
recorded video into a GIF.
Add a caption to the GIF we create and
share it.
We also want the user to have
the option to choose from the album.
And we want to enable at least some
basic editing of the video before it
becomes a GIF.
Let's start with this first task and
break it down a little further.
To convert a newly recorded
video into a GIF we'll need
to present a video camera and
retrieve the saved video.
Convert that video into a GIF and
display that GIF in the UIImageView.
So now,
we get to start with something we know.
Presenting the camera.